a charged atmosphere as jimmy ly
enters the building housing hong kong's
highest court
there's a heavy security presence
unusual for a bail hearing
but this is the first national security
law case to make it to the court of
final appeal
outside they're shouting matches between
pro-democracy activists
jimmy ly supporters and those who want
to see him locked up
we are very angry with jimmy ly he is a
traitor
and used his newspaper to incite riots
and influence young people
jimmy ly is a billionaire with a
rags-to-riches story
and also one of the most high-profile
pro-democracy activists in the territory
he is one of a handful of people so far
to have been charged under the national
security law
that was imposed by beijing in july last
year
these bail proceedings are viewed as an
arena for a struggle between china's
communist
party and hong kong's judiciary
pro-democracy activists say
denying lie bail could impact the rule
of law and set a precedent
the arrested has to prove their own
innocence
before we can even get a bail
and it will become a very useful tool
for the regime
to you know arrest anyone and imprison
you for for weeks if not for for months
before you can get a trial and whether
the trial will be fair
or not is another question it will
fundamentally undermine or even destroy
the principle of common law which has
been practiced in hong kong for decades
in an unusual move for the top court
there are no overseas non-permanent
judges presiding over this case
that's only happened in 10 out of 700
court of final appeal cases
in the last 24 years almost
all courts of final appeal cases enlist
an international judge to sit on the
panel
it's a tradition that underlines the
independence of the judiciary
and shows that the legal system here
upholds international standards
but this time all five judges are
national security law judges
hand-picked by the chief executive the
court of final appeal is seen as the
last holdout against beijing's
increasingly assertive rule
according to hong kong's legal community
the ruling is likely to set the tone for
what could be a large number of national
security cases
if political conditions here continue to
deteriorate
the vigo palin al jazeera hong kong